c'est une vraie aventure il n'ya pas de
triche on a vraiment vécu de super
belles choses non maintenant voilà je
sais dans mon but est coupé le bras deux
ouais si côté la famille salah et donc
ouais et donc apte au travail normal
mais j'ai repris mon travail on que
parce que j'ai pas fait ce que l'on
ressent très naïve l'année prochaine va
retourner leur souhaite
non j'ai pas fait koh lanta pour espérer
autre chose derrière j'ai vraiment eu
peur de télé derrière nolan je m'en fous
temps fou mais j'ai une vie qui est bien
rangé j'ai ma famille et mes non mais
c'est vrai qu'en thématiques ou comme
dylan il a il a 23 ans il est
célibataire il
voilà moi je dise c'est bien pour lui
que si on me propose un public ont même
commencé on propose étudiera quand même
la proposition non mais là par exemple
je ne vais pas le cacher on m'a proposé
pour pour ninja warriors me correspond
tu vas le faire mais je les faits il n'y
a pas de problème mais c'est ce que je
veux dire je vais pas aller faire des
téléréalités que dit l'avenir est fermée
peine on ne va pas faire la paix là des
coeurs brisés ne pas les faire la ville
a déclaré un non alors animateur brisé
dit à blida n'ont même avoue prévoit là
et puis voilà moi en fait kim parce
qu'on parle souvent comme jeudi la
production comme c'était le diable mais
mais moi j étais même après donc très
violente à des personnes oui comme yahia
cityzi qui est là-bas sur place
j'aimerais bien aussi le dire c'est
c'est une personne qui met en place des
infrastructures qui fait travailler tous
les fidjiens qui remettent en village
qui remettent les villages exactement
comme il faut parce qu'ils ont faut
savoir tourner aux jeunes si une zone
cyclonique où les ce sont des cabanes
avec voler les toits sont faites de la
production fait un travail magnifique
mais on parle de la production comme
mémé nous moi en tous cas pour ma part
j'ai jamais jamais noté quelque chose de
négatif
voilà où deux ou de disparités entre les
uns et les autres et ça ça me et ça me
dérange quand je les entends absolument
mais le met personne c'est me
ça oui ça nous des gens qui crachent
dans la soupe tu n'aime pas ça non agréé
bienvenus